s'ouvrait ce sens celui-ci à l'appel de
la capitale dont eto'o et bien j'ai
envoyé ma lettre à 100 députés mais vous
êtes le seul qui m'a répondu tu arrives
to examen pour prise c'est exactement
pour le stage je suis en mission pour la
preuve quand je parle de ma les lundi
vendredi je consacre son bureau du médoc
humeur raconte mans de compte et je suis
une fille du nord mena que je dis je le
sais d'abord parce qu'ils manquent
parricide terre league aujourd'hui
comment il a pu donc pas se créer un
sourire pour rester proche du monde je
demande un mandat clair au parlement
vous en voyez là mais je commençais pas
réglé par même d'un compte et je
trouverais planète
consultez les illégaux vous êtes éditeur
pension jetons pour ceux et celles qui
le veulent bien
la députée conservatrice de plus banal
votre voiture vous allez tout qualité un
conservateur j'ai consommateur paie de
position c'est un endroit à part moi
j'avais la balance du pouvoir la guerre
vous êtes pour ou contre envoyé l'armée
canadienne faire la guerre la situation
ici toutes magnifiques fenêtre de
démocratie directe
je pense que c'est bon d'avoir de
consulter la population vous savez la
paix de 3,6 le bureau du premier
ministre
comment le monde vont me regarder la
fille du cocan vois ma génération en
gamme se voir si tout moyen passant même
longueur d'onde mais on pense que c'est
moins bon mais j'ai bloqué les roues
pour que les algonquins de blocs plus la
voûte ce souhait que d'une même fait
apparaître de super travail commun de
voir ça me suis dit bon je vous dis moi
ce qu'il faut changer
si on part en quête des jo qui
s'équiperont la guerre des post it pour
changer de rythme et ont même avec la
plus grande valeur dit demande pas de
pouvoir elle serait le fun que dont sept
fils avaient voté pour cadre le monde
s'est tu voles des jobs avez vous fini
de nous prendre pour des mélanges
moustiques accord qui n'a pas d'opinion
convoité par hambourg contre 106 5 to et
bâle
c'est quoi ton opinion ces cas là
ce que tu as appris dans tout ça j'ai
appris que je ne savais rien aux boys
des années que j'ai compris ça